[Music]
hey sean what's up brother howard
ah not much man you know i've been doing
this nursing gig up in the masses of
machusitz you have been saving lives in
the northeast up in the cape cods you
know yes yes uh
i have not been up to the cape cod
sounds kind of fancy honestly i've been
out to boston a few times did a
boys trip out there with my brother
actually
not that this podcast is about sports
but sure i flew in one time on monday
went to a patriots game monday night we
went to they played the jets and kicked
the shit out of them um went to the
bruins the next night and then went to
the celtics the third night three nights
in a row of boston sports
and another time i was out there is
actually one of the most
memorable moments in my entire life
um went to a no-hitter there in fenway
park with my brother so
uh clay buckles do it through a
no-hitter as a rookie man that's a
beautiful it was honestly one of the
most amazing things that ever i'd ever
witnessed so well since i've been up
there i've uh
i've i kind of been a little charmed by
the accent they have an accent in the
boston area yeah a little bit yeah not
too no
it's it's like a southern accent except
it's a little guttural but i kind of
like it so uh i thought we need to have
us a cop from boston on here hell yeah
so you don't have to swing a dead cat
very far to find a cop around there
they're everywhere
they have patches on every restaurant in
town so
i found this a guy who's a retired
police officer
uh goes by the name of dale lawrence how
you doing dale
hey what's up fellas nice intro i
appreciate it yes that boston accent
baby yeah
okay before we jump into let's see if
you're a true not an imposter
and pasta i don't know how it would be
said up there let's hear a little boston
give us a little boston
i parked the car in harvard yard
hey kids get over here
here
give me some money
what type of policing are you guys doing
up there hey give me your money wicked
police yeah
but wicked policing yeah dale picked her
drink tonight because he's a low energy
guy would you pick
dale pick some red bull and vodka baby
red bell and voice right here red bull
and vodka we've got that we got what
kind of vodka are you drinking we only
have kettle one
kettle one that's about it for me too
nothing but top shelf brother that's
what we're drinking yeah yeah
this is pretty bougie i don't think this
is russian either we're not supposed to
be drinking russian vodka
i'm gonna get some ice yeah we're gonna
have to put some ice do you drink yours
with ice
i got a whole cup of ice in here my
friend
yeah this one we're gonna do some of
that too
all right
here's to you
there you go guys i appreciate the call
out to come on your podcast
i usually go to bed at 9 30 but for you
guys i'm staying up late brother well we
do appreciate that he also says
broadcast broadcast man so break it down
for us uh you just recently yourself got
out of law enforcement so we're going to
take it back a minute we want to talk
about you know your time as a youth or
that's not maybe that's new york i'm
terrible i'm irish and i can't drop
these boston accents but we'll take you
back to your time as a lad
and uh we'll put you on the path going
into law enforcement
well you know i graduated high school in
probably 1983 at the bottom of my class
i'm pretty proud of that too because if
you can't be an achiever you might as
well be an underachiever it shows you've
got at least some motivation right there
so in 83 i joined the marine corps i was
in the marine corps from 83 to 87
loved the marine corps loved the
discipline loved getting up at five in
the morning going for a run going to the
chow hall the
camaraderie and when i was in the marine
corps i i worked for the embassy
battalion down in quantico virginia i
was stationed over in cairo egypt wow i
was in moscow back in 87 i was in warsaw
poland in stuttgart germany so we're
doing it yes marine corps security guard
and all those places msg or whatever
they call it yeah yeah msg and sophie
back
no great good deal because we had
somebody on recently also we were
talking about msg my brother is msg but
just you mentioned warsaw
i'm going to do a little quick story my
brother and i took a little trip through
europe uh a backpacking thing i don't
know 2004 2005 something like that and
we actually uh
the camaraderie as you mentioned the
marine corps even though he was out he
was doing contract work over at the time
i think in iraq i think he was working
in baghdad
um but we ended up showing up at the uh
the embassy there in warsaw and they
were having their christmas party that
night and they took us in literally just
because you know he had himself had been
a marine corps security guard guy they
let us go in and we got to party
at the embassy in warsaw for their
christmas party that night and then they
hooked us up with some americans that
were local that actually owned the only
tex-mex restaurant at the time in warsaw
poland
we hooked up with these guys and i think
we spent three nights running around
with them and they knew every bar opener
or bar owner
every restaurant every strip club owner
i mean we went out with these guys i
mean did we we had the
we had the best time at that entire
european trip
in warsaw because of the connection that
he had at the embassy there
okay what year was that 2004.
i i was in warsaw in 87 and it was still
it was very uh
your communist you couldn't go anywhere
very structured we had we couldn't do
anything oh yeah yeah
well and i'll say this and no strip
clubs no man and the strip club's there
we're different i promise they're not
like american ones man
but they uh exactly after it was you
know post communist era uh when we were
there and the people still you know you
know a handful years after all that
happened they were still just
celebrating freedom and i mean it was
you know seven eight o'clock at night
all the businesses shut down because
everybody went out to dinners and bars
and partied at night so like all your
shopping was closed everything man it
was just
we had an amazing time there now we did
take time to go see you know the history
from the horrific things that did happen
there but warsaw poland man loved that
place all right so jump back in so man
you uh
did all your marine corps you love the
structure of it obviously he didn't stay
in there forever
now i did four and a half years got out
in 87 and i was literally in college two
weeks later loved college went to a
small community college in beverly
massachusetts
i graduated after four years
and between that time in college i took
a few
civil service exams
and i was lucky enough i got on the
police department back in right around
1991 as a reserve and i worked for
around four years of reserve and in 95 i
got hired full time and from then uh you
know 28 years and
probably the best 28 years of my life
brother great times in law enforcement
great stories it was very similar to the
marine corps great camaraderie
you know i loved working in the
community policing unit i did more or
less community policing my whole career
i wasn't really one of those gung-ho
guys chasing the bad guys down the
street i don't have a lot of bad guys
stories but i do have a lot of funny
comical type stories and like i said
community policing was kind of
my forte as a police officer
well you're a reservist for four years
you said
yeah in massachusetts i'm not sure what
it's like down south but you can work
full-time as a reserve so i pretty much
worked full-time as a reserve and then
was hired full-time in 95 went to the
academy then and
yeah so the four years as a reserve
counts to your retirement which is a
which is a great thing which is a great
thing
a few years less than the 32 that you
have to do well we're here in the south
we don't have and something that i'm
learning from being up there i'm working
at a hospital all the nurses are unions
so
there's a ton of seniority there's a ton
of rules that go on and getting hired on
to a hospital up there is kind of an
ordeal for a nurse which is not like any
place else in the world so
um is that kind of the way it is in
boston too it takes you a while to just
get your foot in the door get your
seniority under you and then you go
yeah law enforcement up on the east
coast at least in massachusetts it's all
unionized and
once you're in
good thing or a bad thing you have
protection of the union sometimes it
works great for offices
other times you get officers who
are out there screwing around but the
union will still protect them so that's
kind of the negative of the union but
overall it's great to be in the union
there's a lot of great protections and
they protect the officer's interest for
the most part and yeah once you're in
the union
uh you you do your 32 years and you walk
out of there hopefully like i did at 55
years of age and start another career if
i had one i don't have one yet
it's a great thing law enforcement on
the east coast i it's a great thing and
a lot of my friends from the marine
corps were down south
in baltimore they were down in florida
in miami
and in los angeles and they got a lot of
horror stories tough law enforcement in
that part of the country very very tough
down south
well in urban areas like
like down south around here every cop
works his beat in a car in boston is
that the way you started out or did you
walk a foot bait
no what happened was community policing
kind of died down after 2000 but prior
to 2000 we had walking beats we had bike
patrol beats we had you know we were in
the schools we had after-school programs
we had a lot of good community policing
but after 2000 all the cops got back in
the cars and started hunting terrorists
right after 9 11 policing up here on the
east coast changed from community
policing oriented to more paramilitary
up here so
we do have walking beats still in the
city that i used to work
it's kind of more on a volunteer basis
they don't force you to get out of your
car but you know community policing for
me
the reason why i liked it so much
because it it brings cops to the
community it brings a sense of trust
most communities that have problems with
law enforcement it's used because the
community doesn't trust the cops they
don't know the cops they don't know the
cops by first name they don't the cops
out in the schools the cops aren't
walking into the businesses talking to
people the cops aren't down at the parks
you know playing baseball or basketball
with the kids so without that community
policing there's no trust in without
trust you see what's going on right now
in the country law enforcement right now
it needs a really big uh makeover
public relations makeover for law
enforcement right now and a part of that
is due to the lack of community policing
after 9 11.
well let me ask you what agency did you
actually work for up there because i
know howard's referring to boston it
sounds like you you're saying for the
agency you worked for did you not work
for boston
i did not work for the boston pd i
worked a little outside of boston
beverly massachusetts
right next to salem massachusetts you've
heard of the salem witches the witches
the small community yeah right on the
seashore
40 000 population we have around 70 cops
and yeah it's like i said it's a smaller
community
every cop that works in that community
is from that community so they're really
tied into the community they're really
committed to the safety of the community
they're committed to the
image of the police department because
they live in that community their kids
go to school there their wives work
there they work there so
i think policing in a smaller community
for me was really um a very positive
refreshing thing from and i i do want to
have a few friends that work for boston
pd and it's it's a hustle it's a grind
it's a lot of stuff going on out there
and um i think sometimes offices and
bigger communities kind of get
lost in the shuffle they get kind of you
know there's not a lot of
personalization in communities like that
and there's a lot of distrust of police
officers in larger communities because
the community doesn't know the offices
well the thing about boston that i've
found in the area up there is that towns
kind of bleed together right so your
town bleeds into the other town i mean
it's hard to figure out when warden town
starts and the next one stops
and yeah i know yeah it's a lot
beverly's pretty close to boston what
are you like 15 miles
about 20 miles away we're right on the
seacoast
right on the sea coast beverly's are
like i said really nice middle-class
community a lot of nice homes here we
obviously we have we have a crime
problem but it's not a crime problem
that's kind of
similar to boston but every community
has their issues every community deals
with certain
crimes that are kind of nuisance to the
community and things of that nature but
obviously it's not a boston or even the
tulsa oklahoma for that matter
yeah you've seen this on the first 48 i
guess or heard about it yeah absolutely
anywhere they do 48 hours you know
there's bad crime there brother that's
it have you seen the comedian by the
name of tom segura he kind of drops a
little he's got a little piece about
that yeah yes i love tom sagor he's
great yeah he does he does have a he
does have i actually my podcast i do it
with a bunch of comedians so i'm pretty
much well connected into the comedy
circle yeah yeah he does he drops a
little piece you know he can he he says
something like it you know i'll tell you
one place i don't ever want to go it's
wherever they film the first 48.
you know so
so close so it's a regular on there so
um all right so man so so they're in
beverly massachusetts you uh you were
doing a little community policing
and uh
give us some
let's hear this little boston accent you
know we got like little drunk
leprechauns running around i mean what
are we doing up there
it all depends i gotta bite what do you
what are you doing where you watching
town
robin banks with nun masks on you got a
guy with a big guy with a samurai sword
oh you know something
funny story we had we have a guy he was
i used to be a boxer
and there was a kid from my boxing club
nice kid really nice kid really squared
away he was a model and something
happened to him i don't know what
happened to him but he had some
psychological breakdown
and in one instance he was in our
community and we got a call for a very
large man
walking down the street waving a samurai
sword and when i say very large he's
about six five three fifty
so we encountered him at a gas station
it was probably two in the afternoon and
he was waving the sword and i knew
exactly who he was because just by the
description there's only one person that
lives in that community that large so we
had an encounter with him we confronted
him and we were able to de-escalate him
and he recognized me even though he was
uh he had some serious mental health
issues at that point in his life with
schizophrenia and things like that but
he recognized me as one of the guys from
the boxing club and he dropped the sword
and we cuffed him up and took him to the
hospital
oh that's awesome yeah that's uh i don't
want to go give it to six five guy with
us with samurai i don't want to box the
six foot five guys
[Laughter]
you just be like walker in the bathroom
on the ground no hell no
so tell us some more about this tell us
about beverly
beverly uh you i guess i got a few you
want some scary story i got scary sexual
like uh
that sounds good
let me let me go with the scary funny
first we got a call it was a real bad
thunder and lightning storm
we got a call for uh for a house the
mother called she says my son's in the
backyard
and he's in the pool and he has a 10
foot long metal rod and he's trying to
commit suicide
he was waiting for a lightning strike
waiting for a lightning strike and we
went there and you know fortunate for
the police officers and in small
communities you usually know
a lot of the guys and we went to high
school with this kid so we were able to
talk him out of the pool
cuff him up take him to the hospital and
kind of calm him down for a few days and
you know he had a pretty productive life
after that but even funny thing about
that i was i was literally in
kindergarten with that kid
when i was in kindergarten with that kid
he had his own special monitor so at
seven or eight years old you knew he was
kind of whacked out and he just carried
it on through the rest of his life man
[Laughter]
when you say he had a monitor right and
he was doing this my first thing was he
probably had broken up with his his only
girlfriend that's usually drives guys to
try to kill themselves but sounds like
he wasn't going to accomplish that the
way he was going
you talking about the the kid in the
pool or the guy with the sword no yeah
like
yeah the kid in the pool he was just he
was just you know unfortunately for him
he was just born that way bad dna
brother
probably his parents probably shouldn't
have had him there was a bad mix of dna
in that family and the kid just came out
kind of whacked out and uh yeah ever
since he was a little kid they knew it
they recognized it and throughout you
know throughout elementary school middle
school and high school he was always a
kid one-on-one with people because you
really couldn't trust them around other
people he was kind of a volatile type
kid
yeah so unfortunately that carry that
carried into his uh adult years
well um
we're going to talk about the big
elephant in the room
your name your name's not dale lawrence
is it
no it's and i guess tonight's my coming
out party and not probably the way you
guys wish
you want to know what happened
as i was getting out of law enforcement
i always wanted to do a podcast and the
one i do right now is inside the line
real stories by real cops and i spoke to
a few offices that i work with a couple
of my good old buddies from the marine
corps are kind of high up in the chain
of command and i spoke to them about it
and they were a little apprehensive
we're a little woke here in boston
there's a little political influence and
police departments up up here i'm not
sure what it's like down south so they
kind of advise me hey if you're going to
do it you might want to come up with a
different name so i said hey you know
something dale lawrence sounds like a
good name to me so the first couple of
podcasts i did is dale lawrence and then
once i retired i said you know something
the name sounded good to me
and everyone was recognizing that as
dale lawrence so i just kept it however
my actual real birth name is brian long
nice irish kid from beverly
massachusetts baby
hello i'm brian long i want to go with
brian long yeah yeah
and porn you know that's a good name for
only fans
you know we've had we had a we had a
young lady that was on here that uh
formerly was a police officer as well
and she had started and only fans up and
she kind of had to play around with that
as well with the department you know
kind of keep it ducked under there for a
little bit a little bit until she
retired then same thing she came out
with her original name and and rocked it
and is doing well from my understanding
i guess
so i guess tomorrow on my podcast i
guess i'm gonna have to come out with my
real name yeah
it's gonna be coming
there's nothing wrong honestly i think
with using uh you know an alias for
something like this it kind of separates
uh especially being in law enforcement
for you know roughly 30 years it kind of
separates the two for you between your
your personal life and your uh your new
your new path you're taking
well we'll tell you we'll share a funny
story with you when we started this
podcast we had to
we had to go through like hell and back
we almost didn't start this podcast
because they didn't like her name
it was too oh really yeah yeah yeah we
we were spot on we knew we wanted
cocktails and cocktails and
uh dan abrams i love you brother he was
uh he's you know kind of backing helping
this thing get started in the company
and
they were they were not fans of the
cocktails portion of it and we thought
it was catchy we liked the
the spin on the spelling difference
between the two um we thought you know
if somebody's looking at podcasts
whether it's in the real you know true
crime world or law enforcement we
thought that just the name kind of stuck
out
and we had numerous
phone calls emails personal text
messages going back that they were they
were not on board with it so our our
producer back in new york sam will we'll
be listening to this and he remembers
these conversations quite well
um but yeah in the end
no harm no foul you know we we
we uh
we landed here with cocktails and
cocktails and i think everybody's happy
and even even they
i guess what's the word apologized or
they saw her they saw the vision correct
correct yeah they thought
i mean we wanted to keep it
light-hearted yeah and that's what this
thing is cocktails do that
so if you think if i tried to rebrand my
podcast to the pd on lsd that wouldn't
go over with you guys that would go over
very well i think you get a whole new
crowd no so here's what you do though
you take you come up with some you know
a different acronym for lsd something
whether it be funny or something law
enforcement and then you can roll with
that all day pd on it lsd it is catchy
you just have a different acronym before
what lsd stands for
there's another one for you sticks i
know we mentioned before we came on our
air about the name purp you never heard
kirk before yeah
i got another one how about you guys
call bad guys perps up there yeah some
not not so much we just probably call
them knuckleheads or shitheads
bad guys like literally bad guy i mean
it's a bad guy you know i don't match
gangsters yeah i mean that's that's the
term you know
yeah how about uh the perps on percocet
purpose yeah get a bunch of per yeah
give them a whole bunch of percocet put
them in a room see if you can solve some
unsolved crimes here see what you can
get them to admit to
get them all fucked up on some perks a
game show all right i'm gonna need some
advice here um
it's coming up on patriots day in
massachusetts can you explain to me what
the hell patriots day is
oh wow
didn't you hear me a few minutes ago i i
graduated the last person in my class at
the high school i went
i don't i'm not 100 sure what it is is
it when uh i don't know when all the
patriots got together and started
kicking the british ass i'm not sure
what it is shit i don't know but i know
we have the we have the boston marathon
yeah
like it's april 18th right
yeah the boston yeah boston marathon
this year
patriots week or and it's a big party in
boston or what is it
yeah just just more the marathon the
marathon would be the big party there's
really no big party here they have a few
parades here and there people get a day
off from work people go out and get
drunk especially in boston the red sox
usually play
that day and the marathon goes on so the
big party would be the marathon all
right well i'm getting some bad
information you know we're in a whole
different world out on the cape you know
it's kind of dead in the winter
so how do you go from tulsa to the cape
i took a plane i actually drove a car
first
now they have these traveling gigs all
over the place so we were able to oh
okay yeah you can they kind of uh i
guess there's like a national i have a
recruiter but there's jobs all over the
place i don't know if you know this well
that's great uh nurses were pretty
popular during the pandemic so we ended
up with
lots of opportunities and i've never
been to the kingdom what the hell i go
out there
howard that's great great
sorry great living down in the cave
brother no yeah yeah jason are you doing
some work over here on on patriots today
for us
some of the first battles
so he said some of the first battles of
the american revolution so there's a
little history lesson
for uh for dale lawrence
and uh there you go lex how's lexington
in concord sound i remember that i know
they had the battle of lexington and
concord am i spot on with that he is
shaking his head and he says yes you are
spot on so
there you go i got to redeem myself on
adjacent sales well i guess the kids get
out of school and shit it's like fair
day here you know how the kids get out
for the tulsa
fucking fair day here oh there you go
you get to go out there we're having a
great time at the fair we dress up like
we're white trash which is pretty much
our normal clothes when we go out there
and play fair games and eat turkey legs
that's beautiful stuff
man so beverly uh beverly massachusetts
uh you know you got on the police
department 911 does happen
what was the change in your department
you know you kind of mentioned being out
of there being out on on literally foot
patrol and that does vary from agency to
agency um you know here in tulsa kind of
only foot patrol we had we have some
downtown we have a lot of bars and
restaurants down there
and we have we had
we had a unit called footbeat and they
actually worked all our housing projects
and we had a lot of crime this was back
in the area you know gangs and dope uh
running around like crazy so we had
different officers assigned complexes
and we were responsible for all of the
calls that went out in there as well as
doing proactive policing so we were out
on foot kind of
i'm not gonna lie we weren't out there
walking around shaking hands and handing
out lollipops
um we were kind of creeping around
trying to catch the gangsters you know
selling dope and stuff like that but it
sounds like a little bit different there
yeah so basically after prior to 9 11
like i said we had a really large
community policing unit we had dare
offices bike patrol we had after school
programs boxing programs literally right
after 9 11
all the funding from that changed
we started uh sending offices to assault
rifle training school we had the fbi and
the atf came into the city and they were
shaken down
any person in that city pretty much who
had an last name that sounded like they
were from the middle east they were
shaking people down they were going in
interviewing people checking for papers
were they there legally or illegally and
some people they had businesses in the
city they owned property in the city and
they were they were deported relatively
quickly out of the city and i'm not sure
if that happened in a lot of communities
but i'm pretty sure it did and that like
i said after 9 11 i think it really is
where a lot of communities especially
smaller communities lost touch with the
community and the police department
became very anonymous at that point and
pretty much cops were like i said they
were thrown back into the cruises and
they were just focused on trying to deal
with whatever was happening out in the
street dealing with the street crime
that was relative to that community and
like i said a lot of the interaction
with the general public the citizens the
kids in the schools pretty much stopped
and i think we're seeing the uh backlash
of that right now in law enforcement
across the country
unfortunately so you're telling me that
like the whole um
the bombing actually took all your funds
from community policing put it into more
like you became the homeland security
branch right
you were basically yeah a lot of the
offices instead of having community
policing units they would have homeland
security offices who all you know they
got trained up on how to recognize
certain
things that are relative to middle
eastern um
you know nationalities and some of the
way terrorist terrorists may operate we
had offices going to computer school to
understand a lot of the stuff that's
happening on the internet and
intercepting things via the internet so
yeah everything changed literally within
months
after that
well
so i'll say this um you know being in
the gang unit i was responsible for for
writing and managing federal grants and
police departments across the country
small big medium size whatever
everybody applies for for federal grants
because you get you know money to help
out your department whether it's funding
on the way you write it up there's very
specific ways the money can be used
there's some stuff that can be used for
equipment some that's strictly used for
equipment there's some that can be used
for overtime you know for investigations
as long as they're all geared towards a
specific goal you know that when you
write this thing up and you've got
performance
you know measures you have to do
quarterly you've got all these reports i
mean they're very paperwork
intense i guess as you manage a federal
grant
so with my position with the gang unit i
wrote numerous grants we received a lot
of them through the years and you know
you're responsible for managing them
because i was in that position as long
as i was i did it through different
presidencies of the country so depending
who was in office
was where the grant money was directed
towards so you get somebody who in my
opinion is very pro-law enforcement hey
we're going to get fucking bad guys off
the street money goes towards we're
going to chase gangsters we're going to
chase you know violent offenders that
type of deal dope you know dope dope
dealers at a certain level and stuff
like that it's put towards that you get
somebody who's office that is more into
wanting to hold hands and you know pat
everybody on the back and tell them hey
we're going to get you fixed even though
they're a bad guy money goes more
towards counseling rehab and stuff like
that so we lose money and i saw that go
on um you know through the years so i
can't speak obviously for the northeast
i was in law enforcement when 9 11
happened we don't have
that type of you know a community of you
know a large number of middle easterners
here in tulsa so we nothing changed for
us in that world but i have seen the way
depending literally who holds
the office of president and how it
trickles all the way down to a police
department in tulsa oklahoma how money
gets spent well do you think that that
has something to do with the uh the
population density that's up there in
the east
i mean yeah absolutely yes sticks hit it
right right on the nose depending on
like down south obviously in tulsa huge
huge gang
issues down there in the florida area
down south so obviously if you take
money from that type of activity
in your streets you don't even be able
to walk your streets with the gang
bangers are out there running the
streets up here in massachusetts there's
not a lot of gang after we do have gang
activity not in the community i work we
have it in boston we have it in the town
called lawrence we have it in
springfield we have it in worcester mass
but in regards to gangs up here
yeah there's not a lot of money spent on
gang enforcement and gang infiltration
up here so whatever the money was spent
on it was like i said it was more or
less community policing they pulled a
lot of the
drug offices out of the schools with the
dare program and they threw it into the
homeland security program well you end
up with a lot of uh well let's use the
dare program as an example one of the
things that i noticed up there is that
in the hospital especially on the cape
we end up with a lot of people who have
lot some pretty serious substance abuse
problems you know so it's just like
every other place in the world there's a
big drug trade that goes on a lot of
people are taking drugs whether they be
over the counter or whether they be
made in the basement kind of drug so was
that some stuff that you dealt with
yeah absolutely and probably right as of
right now i mean every community has a
drug problem whether it be marijuana
fentanyl pills heroin cocaine whatever
it may be
and we've always had that but i think
probably in the 90s is when the
oxycontin hit pretty hard up here on the
east coast
you know hot
yeah and uh from there you had the
heroine so the heroin deaths probably
from 2000 to 2010 on the east coast
doubled and now what you're dealing with
up here is you're dealing with the
fentanyl and not only fentanyl in the
heroin
and in the pills but we've had a couple
of deaths of young kids who are just
smoking the joint they're not drug
addicts they're not heroin addicts
they're not coke addicts they're not
even pill heads they're just a kid
smoking a joint that was laced with
fentanyl so that's what you're seeing
now and obviously you know we know where
that's coming from with the open borders
so
there's no argument on that one right
there
so that's kind of the big thing that
we're seeing up here on the east coast
is just a run-of-the-mill
nice kid smoking the joint dropping dead
because it's laced with fentanyl well
since that money went it came out of
community policing went into homeland
security type stuff has it gone back
since we've kind of
i mean that's
it's been a good 27 years now
uh
21 22. well 21 21. i mean 21 is yet some
change
yeah if you're a progressive police
department i think a lot of them up here
are
becoming more progressive
and you're you're a mayor or you're the
governor or you're a chief a police
chief in the community up here then
absolutely if you know what's going on
in your you know you understand law
enforcement you understand the
importance of community policing a lot
of those programs are slowly starting to
come back especially in the last couple
of years
if you're a progressive like i said law
enforcement official you should know
that uh cops at any point in time are
probably the most disliked and
distrusted at this point
in in the uh in probably the last 50
years so it behooves that officer i mean
i should say that leader of that
department to funnel money back into
community policing and start uh building
trust within the community so what i'm
hearing that only yes so what i'm
hearing you say is that by getting back
to that uh community policing that you
can we could kind of heal this rift that
the public has with the police because i
mean personally i don't think the
everybody knows that we need the police
right i think that it's kind of got
blown out of proportion how many people
dislike the police right
yeah
you know i think if you would uh just
randomly ask people on the street i
think most people would tell you hey
i love the police i respect the police i
want the police however there's just
enough people maybe in the media who
will kind of refute that and spread kind
of a bad narrative and some people will
buy into that narrative and then you
have people thinking that they don't
trust the police so something has to be
done somewhere and like i said i'm a
huge huge advocate of just getting cops
out in the street and that's what i
love to do when i was a co-op and the
guys that i associated with that's what
we love to do because we lived in the
community so we want to feel safe in our
own community we want our schools to be
safe we want to be able to walk down the
street go to the park and not have to
worry about someone giving us a hard
time just because we're a cop off-duty
cop or an on-duty car
so i i think that a lot of that's
starting to come back especially up in
the east coast north shore area of
massachusetts well when you saw when you
uh started obviously you were a
reservist for four years it was kind of
hard to get in what's the climate now
what's the what do the academies look
like how long has it taken a
cadet to get through the academy and get
a full-time position
right around 22 weeks it's been pretty
um
probably in the last 25 years it's been
right around 22 weeks
of intense training
you know to
knock out a great recruit so yeah 22
weeks whatever that equals to months
how's my math doing for about six months
little end of five months your math is
better than howard trying to put
together how long ago 911 was
yeah yeah it's a little bit better than
howard's
[Laughter]
27 years
yeah a little end to six months
right so what uh what are the challenges
of the new police coming out in the in
your area
oh boy
all i know is i have a son not he's uh
he's a comedian and i've always asked
somebody say you don't want to be a cop
do you and he looks at me there's no way
i think you really to be a cop right now
up in the northeast or anywhere in the
in the country you really have to have
some
academic background in regards to what's
going on in society what the actual
facts are when it comes to crime when it
comes to things like racial profiling
and have an understanding on how
society views cops so you can go in
there with a very
objective
view
of how people perceive you and you have
to be uh you have to be
thick-skinned you have to be a great
communicator you have to be reasonable
you have to be likable i mean some cops
you can relate to the stick some cops
just right off the bat they walk out of
the car and people don't like it for
whatever reason they they put out a
persona whether it's their their walk
their talk how they look and nowadays
that's only going to work against you
everyone's videotaping everybody out
there and you don't want to have that
rep so you really have to have your shit
together and you have to be grounded on
who you are and you have to be confident
in your ability and i think you know for
me i'm a great advocate of people from
the military who've done a a good career
in the military whatever service army
navy air force marines coast guard
doesn't matter a lot of those guys
coming out into law enforcement have the
maturity and the just wherewithal to be
able to deal with a lot of the stuff
that's going out in this out there on
the streets right now all right well
i've got a legal question for both of
you and i want to see
[Laughter]
you're
you're my expert cops here okay and i
want to see what the difference is in
tulsa oklahoma okay
and then beverly massachusetts so let's
say that i'm riding my bicycle along
right yep and uh just the little one you
got with the little pink flare things
off the handlebars you have my tricycle
with the basket on the back with hot hot
little flowered howard on the front
tag on it
joshua sitting in the little car seat in
the back end of it i've got him in the
i've got him between the handlebars okay
facing you yeah and his legs are shaved
so i can go faster so i'm riding a bike
along a dog is being walked by an owner
who's not on a leash the dog comes out
runs at me gets in front of me causes me
to wreck
i get up pissed off
and kick the dog because it's still
coming
am i at fault or is the owner at fault
we'll take tulsa oklahoma first what are
we talking about fall for you kicking
the dog yeah no well you can kick the
dog if you're defending yourself so the
dog's coming at you you i mean you said
he's coming at you right aggressive dog
yeah
you have a right to defend yourself okay
your foot is how you are choosing to
defend yourself you're 100 justified in
it no i don't punch down much you don't
punch yeah i don't punch down no i mean
it's a different story if
you're just pissed off at some dog and
you walk over and you know try to kick
field goal with it right so then you're
then you're in some trouble then you've
got some animal cruelties a little
felony charge but you can defend
yourself however you uh you need to even
if it's an animal even if it's an animal
absolutely okay cool well how's it
working beverly
yeah that's pretty much spot on that
that's an easy one let's say uh to jump
ball easy one i mean i guess where you
would go wrong is if you kicked it once
and you kind of knocked it onto queer
street then you started kicking it three
or four five more times and throwing
queer street
equestria i don't know where queer
street is but uh it's when you get we
used to say that in boxing you put him
on queer street you hit him with a
couple of good shots he doesn't know
where he's at
you can't give him the old tulsa
oklahoma beat down brother you give him
one little kick and he the owner grabs
him and they take off and you go on your
way so i can clean that wound up one
kick that's all i get right well i mean
you know as long as you
you know kind of disable the dog and the
dog ain't biting you anymore you're good
to go brother whether it's in tulsa
oklahoma or in beverly massachusetts
what if in this case my uh bicycle is
ruined in this wreck
you you have a civil deal
you pursue it civilly okay against the
owner of said dog okay
these are some legal questions that i
come up with every once in a while i
will i will bill you for these
dogs let me can i ask you a question
hollywood sure
do you are you in like an avid walker
and you on on your route typically in
the morning there's some lady who pisses
you off and she's got a dog and you're
just kind of buying your options out of
this you know what you can do tomorrow
morning
i mean i'm gonna not get a queer street
never heard that before
yeah now i am not an avid walker i i
like to ride my bicycle and
today i was riding my bicycle on some
trails and some people had a dog that
was off its leash and
i had to do everything i could to keep
from hitting it at a high rate of speed
and i was like jesus christ what would
have happened if i would have hit this
dog because i probably would have kicked
it well even yeah even if you had
crashed i mean you'd have a civil type
of deal against this dog because here in
the city yeah
they we do have things they've got to be
on a leash run out there so you'd have a
good civil deal now honestly the person
could be also cited for i mean there's
literally called you know i think it's
like dog unleash i mean there is a city
charge as well for something like that
so the person could be sighted which is
a ticket
and then you'd have a civil litigation
against a person and the reason i'm
asking this is i do also have a bike up
in massachusetts so i want to know if
the law is the same up there if i'm
riding around yeah you're all set howard
you're good to go brother you know it's
kind of funny you ask that question
because people i worked in dispatch for
a while too a lot of guys you you do
some time and dispatch and people would
call the station all the time and they
would ask certain questions and after a
couple of minutes she'd say
are you planning on hurting someone
you're planning on doing something
criminal because what you're asking me
it appears as though you're either
looking to assault your wife i don't
know steal something rob a bank
i need an example
yours is pretty tame though howard so
you're all set brother well give me one
that you got through dispatch
yeah it was unfortunately it was it was
a domestic situation and it was a lady
calling she had a history of domestic
she didn't know that we knew the number
that she called from because you know we
obviously most police departments will
have caller id so we knew who she was
and she was calling about her
boyfriend who she thought was cheating
on her and she was asking what would
happen if i caught my boyfriend cheating
i mean can i punch him in the face can i
hit him with something if he hits me
first can i use a weapon and
you know we had to obviously cut that
conversation off and we had to go to her
house and speak to her and kind of
advise her of her rights because she was
pretty much incriminating herself we
were we were hoping and praying that she
we weren't going to find a body that
sounds like an episode of a week later
in the making
yeah
ahead of time
well dale lawrence aka brian long
we're about to wrap it up
oh that really that fast brother man
that's 45 minutes man it goes quick
doesn't it so man what uh
where can people find you on your
podcast that you've you've got out there
rocking now
it's gonna be insidetheline.org
real stories by real cop so i do that
one i do it with a bunch of comedians
and we also do a soccer heads podcast i
don't know if you guys are into soccer
soccerheadsnew england.com i do that
with a bunch of national comedians we do
it at my house every monday
a real funny bad ass how'd you how did
you get hooked up with comedians man
where'd this come from
well my son's a comedian he's a young
comedian in the boston area he's a
comedian and his manager who runs the
all the comedy in in boston
massachusetts scams comedy a guy by the
name of dave ratigan if you want to be a
comic in boston you either go through
him or you go somewhere else and he's a
good front man he's like howard he's
like howard to you he's a great front
man asked a lot of questions keeps the
uh conversation going and then from
there he has a bunch of other comedians
who are soccer heads
and they love soccer so we just came up
with a soccer head zone podcast a guy
named they play soccer yeah
and the lore
here say the lord lore love that and i'm
still and i'm still looking for a job
i'm still looking for a job through
retirement and uh you know maybe i'll
get one maybe i won't i'm not sure yet
well it was a pleasure having you sir
well i appreciate the invite you guys
are ever up in boston look me up i'm
right in beverly massachusetts howard if
you ever get hooked up down there in the
cape and they arrest you for animal
cruelty throw my name around uh
best thing i can do for i could probably
bail you out howard
i keep some damn money i probably won't
try to hit any dogs
dale brother we do appreciate it man be
careful
all right thanks a lot take care guys